ser periodista en colombia una profesión
de riesgo nada que celebrar en el día
del periodista en la nación andina el
segundo país después de méxico más
violento para la prensa en 2021 667
periodistas fueron agredidos en el
ejercicio de la labor informativa un
hostigamiento que se agravó durante las
jornadas de protestas sociales que
iniciaron el 28 de abril france24 habló
con jonathan vox director de la
fundación para la libertad de prensa en
un periodo de tiempo de dos meses
documentamos más de 340 ataques contra
periodistas y que fuera la fuerza
pública quien estuviera agrediendo pues
por supuesto mandaba un mensaje de falta
de garantías para que los reporteros y
las reporteras pudieran cubrir lo que
sucedía en la calle y sobre todo que no
hubo una posterior sanción a estos casos
ni lass el compromiso que hubo por parte
de la policía de investigar y sancionar
a los responsables la fuerza pública fue
el principal agresor contra la prensa en
uno de cada tres casos ciber patrullajes
estigmatización violencia física son
algunos de los hechos que enfrentan los
reporteros que no tienen garantías de
seguridad como el fotógrafo colombiano
andrés cardona quien durante su trayecto
ha sufrido varios hechos de violencia
perfilamiento desplazamiento forzado la
policía está atacando directamente a la
prensa está disparando está golpeando
está estigmatizando y muchas veces
judicial izando y sobre todo no pasa eso
solo con periodistas que trabajan para
medios nacionales internacionales sino
sobre todo con la prensa local con la
que está haciendo un periodismo regional
por ello organizaciones como la flip
exigen garantías para que la prensa
regional y nacional puedan narrar lo que
sucede en los lugares en el conflicto
armado se ha incrementado las semanas
previas a las elecciones presidenciales
en colombia y hacen una serie de
recomendaciones a las entidades públicas
para la implementación de mecanismos que
garanticen la justicia reparación y
garantías para el ejercicio periodístico
en libertad